l a tutti ragazzi benvenuti che sono
vivi e sono felice oggi siamo tornati
sopra di 13 crono in video un po più da
carnefice rispetto ai soliti buona
visione
io continuo a mangiare perché palle
perché vi sempre maggiore tu metti non
per mille balle per qualsiasi cosa va
bene allora in attesa dei giocatori
veloci che lo scortare le famiglie
facciamo conoscenza innanzitutto velo
people and the best young this game pack
i ferri ma dai ma non sono io non sono
io ok perfetto di vedo io sono dalla
parte opposta della partenza da dio e
preparare attraverso le porte
vedo gente qua e poi qualche st spacca
nel sud no dove sta spaccando le
finestre di una casa e non capisco il
perchè bene perche venga ricordato la
vandalizzata una casa è andato via come
i teppisti ma americani mi ha distrutto
la faccia con un'ascia e poi se vado a
salvare il per spaccio ma sono morto con
i saldi dove sei ore che metta questo
davanti a gela eccoti qua vice paris
spara io non ho paura
io ero la paura succhia però su chi ha
meno
ciao amici ciao amici ma lascio vicolo
cieco sta a casa
ma dai asma e non lo sapevo che era
meglio non certo aiuto aiuto aiuto non
mi segue più se n'è andato ciao jason
no non lo so salve aia taglio al pop
lettone epico finito male
taglia taglia dove sofferenza dove sono
finite sono caduto adesso dopo un ora
potrebbe no con le catene nome ricorda
insegnare patin e forse si sente il mio
jason come non sei tu opposto sono detto
vabbè uccidiamo utente ma ci siamo forti
la forza delle persone quando ci
mettiamo d'impegno no io ero cavalca
attenzione sente la musichetta
bellissimo quadro di una giusta
musichetta viola o quella musica invece
la droga
se non fa paura ma come una terrificante
quella sbarra le porte perché ho paura
che i tagli infatti la donna
mica che madonna che cade no vabbè non
vuoi capire che va bene ha staccato un
braccio di giuro non ho mai preso un
jump scheri venerdì 3
mi sono cagato addosso è spuntata la
faccia dalla porta
se tu guardi mi chiami sono mi sono
avvicinato alla porta eccole spuntato
dal nulla resen tradotto miliardi ma che
vi sto mangiando la gamba la smetti
l'import una del marco arpa lo aiuto
familiare
[Applauso]
beh questo è un modo alternativo vuoi
kutlak rolling 7.50 euro
chi infatti muovendo grande ma inizierà
a fare live largo e ragazzi domani sera
sul mio canale adesso ciao pietro ruta
fare augurato buona fortuna vai dollari
dagli buona fortuna ma la fortuna
carissima adesso ammazzo pietro e poi ti
dico pare cosa penso non è successo
no da ballo ho detto a posto adesso a
marzo pietro hai capito noi noti a
milano dove sei in basso si spara in
alto a destra
se in basso a sinistra quindi io vengo
qua ciao allora no dai lo sa la porta
bene a qualcuno va dentro
devo già massacra tutti dove pensi
nasconderti dove pressi di nasconderti
l'ho preso così cresciuto del sangue eva
è quanto disastro fatto non ci sono
sotto il letto
sono stato furbo quanto io ci si perde
sono già iniziati
l'altro secondo me ciao persona bella
tutto bene come andiamo allora siamo
ottimisti
ok cosa succede oddio ma cosa sta
tagliando l'aria vabbè vabbè tranquilla
ma che questa casa audio è aperta bravi
bravi bravi jarvis come buttare il
proiettile complimenti
sabato mi sono fatto paura da solo in
questa cosa che ho fatto
ciao
poverino tieni frate buona morte mi
dispiace perché per un attimo poteva
salvarsi insomma c'era walter è tutto un
sacco ciao è un piacere averti qui come
stai
ascoltami stato non posso citare
all'inizio no non puoi questa persona ha
offeso la mia persona e quindi inizierò
ne facciamo perché siamo già amico a
vieni qua mi piace giocare con te
mettere la macchina della pesa lì perché
non metti alla macchina tragico distorto
la butta qui basta scotch e non altro la
dentro giallo tanto che già il sen
ma come accalappiatori l'ho beccato un
pizzo che che sta per prendere la
macchina aspetta migliorate trasportare
per ucciderlo ma è la xj6 a chiamata che
male ma fatto
oddio c'e un po di bianco ma visto che
figata
e stato bellissimo non mi aveva visto
manco per sbaglio fatto un chapter come
prima hanno fatto a me ciao frate
vorrebbe che ho visto non si è
dimenticato i ranghi di qua allora stato
continui a scappare bilancio un coltello
nella schiena va bene va però anche
detto rega ma chi pensate con chi
pensate di avere a che fare ben i quadri
deriva matttinata michela vecchi dalla
danni della ventilata michela vieni
cover mi ma figurati se che cover mi
ammazzo tutti vi ammazzo tutti in sala
sarà è anche un deficiente amica aiuto
sei un pirla e fatelo dire però i fatti
non può per me è bella
sei riuscito dal cofano aiuto aiutati e
salvati
ma cosa hai tratto li ha lasciati tutti
indietro di noi
la lasciate qui tutti hanno lasciati
tutti indietro ci avrete uno solo se
salvato hai finito di rompermi le palle
magarity spazzò via anche il cugino
tutta la famiglia ai cognati e tutto il
resto ex fastidio via a questa persona
dove sei tumore sto cercando di fermare
una macchina che è partita ma non ci
riesco è uscito a tommy jarvis concido
la cellula partita cito da è uscito è
quello con la macchina mi sa che riesce
a scappare perché non riesco più a flash
hurley però c'è uno che è uscito aveva
un fucile ma sei tu non sei solo cairo
ma ti pare basta mi fai paura tablet o
cucine schifoso bravo bravi è bellissimo
è stato bellissimo
complimenti da tre morto non si sa come
va bene il bagno open enti sul suo
destra è tra lei e il muro proprio in un
check raise
eccoci vista su per sparare eccoli
allora ok girati reti lascia caserta
cosa mamma mia lo scarico del centro non
ti faccio un coltellino svizzero
buttarlo dentro un eccessiva aveva ma
non si sa muovere questa è l'unica
opzione che offre charme ii vedere se le
scarpe
tra prendo vinto se non penso lei a
white ne vado
[Musica]
aia il dolce suono della carne tritata
sì sì brizio miniature spinta finale ma
dove pare è conflitto sono uno sono gli
altri due li ho ammazzati 7 su 8 altri
usi sono disconnessi mentre ammazzava
uno è fuggito per 120 ragazzi questa è
la mia video su bella di 13 spero vi sia
piaciuto spero che abbiate passato un
buon venerdì è però state passando o
magari state operando questo video
mentre e lunedì nel 2025 quindi spero
che vi sia piaciuto cose che ci piace
come te piace a quelli dove si tiene
decidiamo di
[Musica]